at apple we are focused on creating
innovative products and experiences
netflix kicked off big tech earnings by
reporting a surge in subscribers google
we actually do have the ability to make
more of an impact on people our company
is now
meta good morning let me show you what
we've been working on
we're going to take a couple of minutes
to walk you through how we hire at
google first
is one of the most used
attractions
[Music]
hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and i'm a former software
engineer turned content creator before
youtube i worked in silicon valley
building ios apps my journey with
technology started when i declared my
major in college to computer science i
was looking for a job where i could be
financially stable after college and cs
was the quickest way for me to get there
well being able to apply my skills to a
breadth of different companies products
and problems and to help people with
technology i remember in college like
somewhere around sophomore and junior
year when you start planning about life
after college there were a handful of
companies that everybody wanted to work
at facebook apple amazon netflix and
google
otherwise called fang or mang now that
facebook is called meta i don't know
yeah like whatever the new acronym is
throughout my career it felt like
getting a job at one of these like large
successful companies was like the thing
to do if you're an actor you go to
hollywood and if you're a software
engineer you get a job at a fan company
it was almost seen as like a rite of
passage like once you landed that fang
job people thought you were legit and
then you had kind of like made it i
remember when any one of my college
classmates got a job at one of those
companies people would find out and like
their popularity status was sore at
school and even in the 2010 edition of
cracking the coding interview basically
the de facto study guide for software
engineering interviews
each big tech company is called out
about what makes their interview process
unique it's also in the newest edition
too and it kind of makes you think like
yeah maybe you should interview at these
companies because they're the ones
specifically called out in the guide and
honestly despite all that i was never
like super pulled to want to work at a
fang company i'd heard things about the
work culture at each and it just didn't
really seem like it would be a great fit
for me i'm someone who'd rather like
collaborate with someone over competing
with them i also don't do super well
with like work stress and honestly like
i heard the technical interviews were so
hard that i didn't even really want to
try of course throughout my career the
image of big tech has changed
drastically too which kind of all the
more gave me the reason to like not want
to work there things like election
interference spreading misinformation
and enabling conspiracies taking part in
genocides and violating antitrust laws
but i still hear all the time how these
are the most sought after employers in
the tech industry and you know
eventually i did actually end up at a
fan company i worked at netflix for a
little over a year after wanting a
change of pace from the startup world
and i happened to find a great match
with my team and my manager which
mattered the most to me in finding my
new role it didn't really matter to me
that the company belonged to fang
necessarily so looking back at my own
journey and talking to those who were
just getting started in theirs i
couldn't help but wonder why do people
want to work at fang companies i knew my
own reasons for why i did shouldn't want
to work at fang but what were other
people's reasons i mean there are so
many different job opportunities in the
tech industry so much so that tech
employees usually switch jobs every one
to two years on average so similar to my
video that i did about japan's tech
industry i decided to do my own research
i read articles papers and talked to
people from lots of different
backgrounds all at a different point in
their career journey and it basically
came down to three reasons
the pay and perks prestige and the
caliber and just a heads up this video
along with really all of my videos
contains my subjective and qualitative
findings so none of the things presented
here are going to be like objective or
unbiased or anything like that basically
i am human and these are my thoughts
[Music]
so yes the money that you get from
working at a fan company is good i'm
guessing that a lot of people are
wanting it to build things like
generational wealth and financial
stability and heck maybe even rise
through an economic class in the united
states in a world where things are only
getting more expensive and the gap
between the wealthy and the poor is only
getting wider getting the pay that you
do at fang i thought would be key in
helping to build things like
generational wealth and possibly break
through socioeconomic classes which i
certainly think that's true but when it
came down to like the real honest
personal reasons for why the things that
like pay and perks enable for a lot of
folks is stability one thing i had one
plus about google especially the team i
was on it had a great work life balance
so i was able to get my job done but
then be home with my son um on top of
the great pay and the benefits like
after graduation my main concern was
really just getting a job that can
provide financial stability for me
personally at the time because i didn't
have any internships and i didn't really
have
any background up until of like tech up
until the last year i was really just
wanting to find a job and so whatever
job that could provide that financial
stability that was really like my main
goal for me to live a decent life decent
comfortable life i didn't have much
growing up obviously like we had enough
to get by and even small luxuries here
and there both my parents were working
and they would be a plate and we had to
like ask other family members to help
take care of me and my sister there are
times when like we also have to kind of
look out for ourselves and kind of just
be careful a little bit especially
because my parents also i guess that's
another values like to be frugal with
your money make sure that you only spend
where you need to spend
i don't i guess i i wanted to have a
life that didn't feel like i had to be i
guess too cautious with my choices where
like if i have to make an emergency
decision to do something i'm not
um at the losing end like i'm able to
kind of just recover quickly or just
like not worry about anything and then
also like for me like i want to help out
my parents once like i have enough money
you know i pay off all my debt and stuff
i want to make sure that i'm able to
provide for like my parents and then
especially whenever i decide to have a
family i want to be able to provide for
them so financial stability life
stability job stability are all things
that people in and outside of tech need
obviously when we think about what
overall has contributed to that
economists look towards things like the
2008 financial crash and obviously covid
in the last two years has had many of us
re-examine what we truly need to survive
and you know i found that in a survey
that i put out to a lot of people
younger folks or people who are earlier
in their careers as software engineers
are more likely to want to work at fang
because it's a one-way ticket to
civility which makes sense because if
you're in your younger years or you're
just trying to become independent then
you need the money to build stability in
your life granted even with these really
high salaries i will say that if you're
gonna live and work in the bay area it's
not exactly super life-changing and
that's because to no surprise the cost
of living is incredibly high so yes in
this whole thing pay is a really large
component but perks are too things like
work visas to be able to live and work
in the united states work visas take
like money time and resources from a
company to work with the us government
to get so it makes sense that these like
really big companies that have a lot of
money and resources are more willing to
sponsor and while we're talking about
perks a lot of these big tech companies
have really nice amenities in their
office for their employees to use but i
will say that no one really mentioned
that as like their primary reason for
wanting to work at fang sure you get
like all these perks right you get paid
while you get food you get ping pong
tables whatever i think maybe it might
be
something that's influenced during
college like let's say
your freshman you're taking your classes
and you have like a junior who just came
back from
like a facebook internship and they talk
about like how much money they made what
the experience was like all the swag
that they got and so that kind of leaves
a mark on you as like a freshman you
know student and you're just like oh wow
that sounds like a good place to be like
[Music]
so i don't know about you but when i was
in high school and choosing which
college to attend prestige mattered even
though i didn't know as much about the
world back then as i do now i did know
that the name of the college could play
a huge factor in my future i mean people
just look at those who went to an ivy
league school differently and fang also
has this kind of air of prestige too i
mean these are the world's top tech
companies they make a lot of money and
they have a really big impact and so
people look at you differently when
you've got xfang in your twitter or
linkedin bio or your resume honestly i
was just like so excited to put the x
googler in my twitter bio just because
that has its own prestige and hype to it
so
and yeah honestly i've seen this in my
own experience i used to get comments
questioning the validity of my software
engineering skills all the time on my
videos but after i revealed that i
worked at netflix to my audience those
comments all but disappeared and people
started calling me x netflix engineer my
yuko and they just treated me
differently so working at a fan company
is kind of like getting another chance
at getting into an ivy league school if
anything it's probably better because
you can apply to fang many times
throughout your career oh hey there
enjoying the video
good well i'm just here to tell you that
in case you're someone who's looking to
land a job at a fan company then i've
got an incredible interview resource for
you interviewing.io is a sponsor of
today's video and they conduct realistic
coding interviews led by senior software
engineers who'll give you detailed
feedback about what you need to work on
in order to land that fang job they have
the largest network of vetted and
experienced tech interviews in the world
so you can book an interview with as
little as 24 hours notice the best part
you don't pay anything until you're
hired so click the link in the
description box for more details thank
you interviewing.i o for sponsoring and
now let's get back into the video so
then why is the prestige important
anyways is that based on like someone
else's personal values that like maybe
they want the recognition or does it go
deeper than that
having one of these top companies that
are very well renowned on my resume and
as an experience will then help me land
better roles at other companies in the
future so i know at some point i want to
try working for a startup and kind of
see what that environment is like but i
feel like that would be easier once i've
had this experience at a big major tech
company and something that i've noticed
that's really interesting that i've
heard from a lot of people is that a lot
of them will choose to take their return
offers from the fan company and they'll
say things like oh i know i only want to
work here for like one to three years to
like gain the experience in like the
title um because i think being able to
say like x google or like x facebook is
still like mean a lot in the industry
like it still holds a lot of weight just
because it's easier to know that thing
in microsoft and like all those
companies that are the top dogs they've
already established their presence in
the technology space and because they
have that establishment it's easy to
look for
opportunities to grow and just to be
like okay i was able to do this i'm i'm
the stuff i
was able to prove myself prove my own
self-worth what fang does with its
prestige for individual people is that
it brings a sense of legitimacy to your
skills having it on your resume is kind
of like a stamp of approval of some
sorts that generally a lot of people
value it's the name thing for me again i
feel like it can open more doors and
people could be kind of more trusting i
guess of just like the knowledge that
anyone with the x in their name can put
out just because they got that stamp and
i worked here but you know i moved on
like imagine you're looking for a job
and you come across two different
startups and you're just trying to get a
sense of who they are and kind of suss
em out one has leaders who have prior
fang experience versus one without how
would you feel about the one with
ex-fang leaders versus the one without
the answer is probably actually gonna
look different for everybody but i think
that most of us can agree regardless of
whether like the fairness and validity
of using x-fang as a measuring stick is
valid that it can just help to have fang
on your resume especially so if you're
out there trying to prove yourself maybe
you're a new grad who's trying to
differentiate themselves from their
peers and you're trying to prove that
you deserve a seat at the table or maybe
it's because you're a minority in tech
and because you don't look like the
majority people don't automatically
trust that you have great skills
unfortunately i am a black woman that
program so yeah i mean this is the
industry that's dominated by white men
and i'm the complete opposite of that so
i always feel like i have to do a little
bit extra prove myself a little bit more
to get an ounce of the same respect when
you get that legitimacy through prestige
then it opens up new doors in the long
term and if in the future you come
across an opportunity that you really
want to pursue then that prestige can
help you to get that and do what you
want in life
[Music]
so if you ask a random person that you
know regardless of whether they're in or
out of tech i'm willing to bet that they
know all the companies in the acronym
again they're some of the most
prestigious companies in the tech
industry they've become common household
names because of the huge impact they've
had on our society facebook changed the
way we connect with others amazon
changed how we shop apple changed our
relationship with our devices and
netflix changed the tvs and movies we
watched and of course google defined how
we use the internet when it comes to
software engineers whose entire job is
about curiosity and problem solving and
learning how things work i think working
at fang is like a really enticing
rubik's cube to solve
that's kind of the reason i started
loving development to begin with because
i realized with doing something as
simple as making code on a tech center
like vs code like you can build these
products that literally change the world
it's almost like a superpower really
because like you feel like you can
literally do whatever you want if you if
you're imagined enough if you're
creative enough or if you are in tune
enough to what society needs you can
create a product that can change the
world and that's kind of why that's one
reason why i fell in love with uh coding
and software development to begin with
eventually you can't help but wonder how
these companies got so big so ubiquitous
and so successful over time i think just
the curiosity takes over i'm i'm the
type of person that like if you present
to me like the fundamental theorem of
calculus or something i ask you to like
can you prove that to me why does that
exist i am a fan of working at a large
organization because it's more people to
interact more be like to get to know
right the whole connections point and i
would also consider
meta as a place too is because when
facebook rebranded us
from from just being facebook to meta it
really essentially expanded their
identity right like they um want to go
into different space if i had the
opportunity i'd want to be a part of
that journey to like see how do they
make those connections in slightly
different spaces but still with people
but um for different purpose and
different contexts there's a saying that
you should work with people who are
smarter than you
mostly help you grow in your own skill
set and so that you have a learning rich
environment and interestingly i found
that in my interviews the further along
in your career you are the more you're
going to prioritize things like growth
and learning opportunities and curiosity
as a top reason for how you're going to
make an employment decision and there's
definitely the image that the people who
work at these companies are high caliber
i mean at the very least they all pass
the really difficult technical interview
process after all which in my opinion i
feel like that's just like one type of
assessment for one type of smartness in
a technical interview but we can get
into that in another video
[Music]
anyway why do all of these things matter
we found the answers to why people want
to work at these companies at an
external level the pay in perks the
prestige and the caliber but why do
people care about these things what are
the fundamental values and perspectives
that lead you to one company over the
other and what are the real honest like
personal reasons why people want to work
at fang well
it's because people want to work
somewhere they care about with kovid and
the many big world events that happened
before that and personal life events and
lessons that we learn throughout our
lives we learn what matters to us and we
take steps to make things a reality to
live the way that we want we see this in
the great resignation a movement where
millions of people are quitting their
existing jobs to find better ones that
suit them we find out how we want to
spend our time and who we want to spend
it with and try to make our limited time
as human beings as meaningful as
possible
i don't want to be a fake person to
myself i want to be someone who is
genuine in all aspects of my life
whether that be
my personal relationships with my fiance
or with my friends or with my family and
also with my job because if i don't if i
work for a company that doesn't align
with like what my mission and vision and
my own life is i feel like i'm going
farther and farther away from like the
mission and vision of my life i guess
talking to people who are older than me
they would say a lot like oh this is
what you spend like 40 hours a week
doing and so like you might as well
hopefully enjoy like a little bit part
of it working on projects that i feel
like i'm making a difference at so i've
worked at companies where i felt like i
wasn't doing anything i was just sitting
there and when i did stuff it would
never translate to like the final
product so i don't want to be wasting
time so
it's kind of uh when you're in that
experience of just sitting there and
trying to
find stuff to do and kill time it really
kind of gets to you
and
you're just looking at the clock all day
and what you want the most is to you
know leave and go do your own thing so
obviously every individual person has
different needs to do life and that also
changes throughout our lives for some
our jobs are there to enable us to live
and so it doesn't matter too much what
you work on so long as it doesn't
compromise your own values too much but
i think the balance starts to shift when
we move forward in life as we get older
and big life and world events happen and
we realize we're not invincible that we
place more importance on finding meaning
and purpose in our work a lot of us in
the tech industry have the privilege to
choose where we want to work so why not
take that opportunity and find something
that we like chances are we're going to
do better at her job learn more and have
so much more fun along the way and you
know for some people fang is where they
want to go so why the heck do people
want to work at fang well
it all kind of depends
thank you so much for watching this
video i really hope you liked it i just
want to say a quick thank you to
everybody i interviewed for this video
really appreciate your time and energy i
also want to say thank you to my
research advisors who help me to get
unstuck and figure out what the heck i'm
doing make sure to subscribe to my
channel if you want to see more videos
like this because i'm going to be doing
more of these in the future so i'll see
you very soon
[Music]
you